- [Instructor] We're told that triangles,
let's see, we have triangle PQR
and triangle ABC are congruent.
The side length of each square
on the grid is one unit.
So each of these is one unit.
Which of the following sequences
of transformations maps
triangle PQR onto triangle ABC?
So we have four different
sequences of transformations.
And so why don't you pause
this video and figure out
which of these actually
does map triangle PQR,
so this is PQR, onto ABC.
And it could be more than one of these.
So pause this video and have a go at that.
All right, now let's do this together.
So let's first think about sequence A.
And I will do sequence
A in this purple color.
So remember, we're
starting with triangle PQR.
So first it says a rotation
90 degrees about the point R.
So let's do that and then we'll
do the rest of this sequence
So if we rotate this 90 degrees,
so one way to think about it is
a line like that is then
going to be like that.
So we're gonna go like that.
And so R is going to stay where it is.
You're rotating about
it, but P is now going
to be right over here.
One way to think about
it is to go from R to P,
we went down one and three to the right.
Now when you do the
rotation, you're going to go
to the right one and then up three.
So P is going to be there
and you could see that.
That's the rotation.
So that side will look like this.
So that is P and then Q is
going to go right over here.
Once again also do a 90
degree rotation about R.
And so after you do the
90 degree rotation PQR
is going to look like this.
So that is Q.
So we've done that first part.
Then a translation six units
to the left and seven units up.
So each of these points
are gonna go six units
to the left and seven up.
So if we take point P,
six to the left one, two,
three, four, five, six.
Seven units up one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
It'll put it right over there.
So that is point P.
If we take point R, we
take six units to the left.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Seven up, one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven
it gets us right over
there and then point Q.
If we go six units to the left one, two,
three, four, five, six.
Seven up is one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven
puts us right over there.
So this looks like it worked.
Sequence A is good.
It maps PQR on to ABC.
This last one isn't an R
this is a Q right over here.
So that worked, sequence A.
Now let's work on sequence B
on this in different color.
A translation eight units
to the left and three up.
So let's do that first.
So if we take point Q, eight
to the left and three up.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Three up, one, two, three.
So this will be my red Q for now
and now if I do this point R.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Let me make sure I do that right.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Three up, one, two, three.
So my new R is going to be there
and then last but not least
point P, eight to the left,
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Three up, one, two, three.
Goes right there.
So just that translation
will get us to this point.
It'll get us to that point.
So we're clearly not done mapping yet,
but there's more
transformation to be done.
So it looks something like that.
It says then a reflection
over the horizontal line through point A.
So point A is right over here.
The horizontal line is right like that.
So if I were to reflect,
point A wouldn't change.
Point R right now is three
below that horizontal line.
Point R will then be three
above that horizontal line,
so point R will then go right over there.
Just from that, I can
see that this sequence
of transformations is not going to work.
It's putting R in the wrong place.
So I'm going to rule out sequence B.
Sequence C, let me do
that with another color.
I don't know I will do it
with this orange color.
A reflection over the vertical
point through point Q,
sorry, a reflection over the
vertical line through point Q.
So let me do that.
So the vertical line through
point Q looks like this.
You can draw that vertical line.
So if you reflect it Q is going to be,
it's going to stay in place.
R is one to the right of that,
so now it's going to
be one to the left once
you do the reflection.
And point P is four to the right
so that's gonna be for the left.
One, two, three, four.
So P is going to be there
after the reflection.
And so it's going to
look something like this
after that first transformation,
unless it's getting a little bit messy.
But this is what you probably
have to go through as well.
So I'll go through it with you.
All right, so we did that
first part the reflection,
then a translation for to
the left and seven units up.
So four to the left and seven up.
So let me try that.
So four to the left,
one, two, three, four, seven up.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So it's putting Q right over here.
I'm already suspicious of
it because sequence A worked
where we put P right over there.
So I'm already suspicious of
this but let's keep trying.
So four to the left and seven up.
One, two, three, four.
Seven up One, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
So R is going to the same
place that sequence A put it
and then point P one, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Actually it worked.
And it works because this is
actually an isosceles triangle.
So this one actually worked out.
We were able to map a PQR
onto ABC with sequence C.
So I like I like this one as well
and then last but not
least, let's try sequence D.
I'll do that in black
so that we can see it.
So first we do a translation eight units
to the left and three up.
So we start here.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
three up, one, two, three.
So I'll put my black Q right over there.
So eight to the left
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Three up, one, two, three.
I'll put my black R right over there.
That's actually exactly
what we did in sequence B the first time.
So P is going to show up right over there.
So after that translation sequence...
First translation in sequence
D it gets us right over there
Then it says a rotation negative
270 degrees about point A.
So this is point A right over here
and negative 270 degrees.
It's negative, so it's
going to go clockwise
and I'll see 180 degrees.
Let's say if we were to take
this line right over here
if we were to go 180 degrees,
it would go to this line like that
and then if we go to another 90 degrees,
it actually does look like
it would map on to that.
So this is actually looking pretty good.
If you were to this line right over here
well then if you go negative 270 degrees,
we'll map on to this right over here
and then that point R will
kind of go along for the ride.
It is one way to think about it
and so it'll go right over there as well.
So I'm actually liking sequence D as well.
So all of these work
except for sequence B.